[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our
webinar here at simply learn i'm your
host dan beaver and we're going to be
talking about the pros and cons of ping
for social placement with Matt Bailey
and Matt is going to introduce himself
in a moment here but I just wanted to
give a little heads up about him he is
the best-selling author and marketing
expert is a corporate trainer
professional speaker and he's also the
digital marketing instructor for the
Direct Marketing Association in New York
City and a member of the digital
marketing faculty for simply learning so
hi Matt how are you oh there we go right
well I had how are you doing I'm doing
okay it's good to hear you so everyone I
just want to do a little bit of
housecleaning before we get started and
that is for those of you that are new to
webinars or even new to WebEx let me
give you a little rundown of how to
interact with this here everyone is
actually muted except for Matt and
myself and but if you want to ask a
question we encourage that because
throughout the throughout this webinar
if there's something that relates to a
slide feel free to ask ask us a question
there are two ways to do that one is
through the Q&A function which is
located in the upper right hand corner
of your screen so just click on that and
you can select who you want the question
go to whether it's Matt or the panelists
or the host or everyone in general and
there's also the chat function so those
two functions we encourage you to just
to send us a private message with your
questions will also be pausing at about
20 minutes in to maybe ask any questions
people might have up to that point
you'll stay muted but we'll read your
questions and that will answer them as
they come on and then of course at the
end we'll have another following Q&A
there so with that I like to hand this
over to to Matt who's going to share
with us all these deep dark secrets
about social placement and
why you might want to actually pay for
it yourself rather than just go to your
organic route hey Matt hey thank you so
much for the introduction I really
appreciate that and yes we're going to
dive into the world of paying for social
placement and of course is with any type
of marketing outlook when we start to
evaluate this as with anything I'm going
to recommend that you look at anything
with a healthy amount of skepticism we
are constantly bombarded especially in
the marketing industry with the latest
fad the latest news the darling of the
media they love different apps different
trends and so we always need to keep an
eye on those things and we need to
understand that not everything is going
to work for everybody all of the time
and so I'm going to walk through some of
the things that we absolutely need to
know from a paid placement standpoint
I'm also going to be presenting the good
and bad of what to expect as you dive
into it now one of the things that you
absolutely have I'm sure seen as you
have you've done any marketing activity
whatsoever that the organic reach of
your social channels is probably
trending down main reason is that there
is so much information that is just in
the funnel to be shown to each
individual person our news feeds are
constantly being bombarded not just by
our friends our acquaintances or
connections but also advertisers that
want to reach us and so there has to be
some limits and things have to be scaled
down and so your organic reach is down
significantly from what it was just a
few years ago maybe even a few months
ago one of the big problems when it
comes to especially social is the lack
of clear metrics or the ability to track
what you are doing and what you are
getting out of it so we're going to
identify some of that and some ways that
you can combat that but ultimately this
is the one of the bigger
for marketers the third is that I'm
amazed at how many people get into
social media or use social media as an
end unto itself rather than as a part of
an overall strategy to engage with their
audiences and so it comes down to your
goal what are you trying to accomplish
and if everything all of your marketing
budget is focused on engaging in social
media you may want to take a step back
and look at what you're doing and what
you're expecting from it and also your
bigger goal of what you're trying to do
in reaching your audience now I say this
because from the first point we've all
seen our organic reach getting smaller
now that's mainly because these social
companies that are offering these
services they need to monetize somehow
what better way to monetize than to make
advertisers pay more to reach more
people and one of the ways they've been
able to convince people to do that is by
limiting your access to your followers
now if you want to reach more people
you're going to have to go the promoted
route because that will then enable you
to reach the greatest amount of people
possible your organic posts are going to
be limited they're going to be throttled
back because it's in their best interest
for you to pay for placement now the
other side of this is dark social which
you are paying to reach people that
reach a success a significant
requirement now that requirement could
be a cookie someone that has visited
your site and interacted with your
website they've got a cookie and so you
can target them through social channels
but you have to pay to do that
so really what's happening with social
media it's becoming a pay-to-play
proposition and so you need to become
more aggressive and how you view social
marketing because they're in it for the
money and you are the money that they're
in it for and
so knowing how to reach people and the
best ways to budget for specific
messages is going to be critical in the
coming years now one of the problems and
this is specifically for Facebook is
that as advertisers have paid to boost
posts or create campaigns advertise
third sites like Facebook are miss
reporting numbers they're overestimating
video views they have different
definitions of what is a view when sold
to an advertiser as to what they do
internally and so Facebook has had a lot
of problems with advertisers the only
thing is as much as advertisers would
say they don't trust Facebook
advertising on Facebook is going up and
people are paying more mainly because
that's where the audience is and that's
how you can reach them really it comes
down to this Facebook snapchat LinkedIn
you have to look at this as it's
somebody else's audience really it's a
second party it's their platform it's
their audience even though they follow
you you don't own them you see it's it's
the social media it's Facebook that
determines if your organic post is going
to reach your audience and how much of
it will reach and so they're the ones
that are monetizing their platform it's
their metrics and their audience you're
only renting it and so because of that
we need to have our goals aligned to
what or organic posts going to do for us
what our sponsored posts going to do for
us and what do we want people to do when
they see those posts you see the whole
goal of marketing through social
channels is ultimately to bring people
to your own properties because then you
can track what they do what they
download what are they interested in and
how do you engage them not just on that
social platform but by bringing them
back to your site whether it is for lead
generation lead nurturing customer care
or customer advocacy
having that customer journey and what
you want to accomplish in front of you
at all times will help you then engage
better in social channels in order to
drive people to those destinations now
very important for us to remember is
that people don't use social channels
the same way people use different
channels for different activities and
there is an old saying that is very true
especially in social media that says the
medium is the message what that means is
that how you receive information the
medium or the media through which you
receive that information will in large
part determine how much you read or how
much credibility or how much attention
you give that information I created this
chart to help us understand how people
engage with content based on how they
see it
you see if you're reading an article
online you're going to be this is the
this is where you're the most engaged
chances are you're researching something
so you're on a page and you are reading
about it now think about what's on the
page the context of the information is
very high whereas the competition for
your attention is very low and so
because of that this medium of an
editorial format of an article is high
on your interest and engagement level
the same with video now there might be a
little more competition because we've
got some related videos down the side
we've got other things popping up on the
video but the context is still very high
same thing when you're doing forums or
something like that now a little more
competition for your attention is
creeping into the viewing area but the
context is still relatively high now
when we look at social media like
Twitter snapchat or Instagram
information is happening very quickly
it's it's streaming through as it
happens and the problem here is that
there's very little context to the
information the context is determined
based on who your file
and who you're following could be for
different reasons and also what they're
posting could be for very different
reasons and so you have this constant
flow a very disparate information and
it's a high level of competition for
your information because there's
constant information flowing through
there and so how people engage is in
large part dependent upon how the medium
or the channel through which they are
engaging that certain channels will grab
people's attention more than others and
we can see this because when people come
from each of these channels we can in
large part predict how they are going to
act when they click on a link from any
one of these channels people that click
on a link from Twitter or snapchat are
typically going to be at that page for
about 10 seconds or less and then
they're going to leave people that click
on a link from an article will tend to
stay longer do more and they will
convert at a higher rate search is
somewhere in the middle because you
determine the context for your search
and the competition is largely
predictable but the other search results
on the page so what's your plan how are
you going to engage your audience and
already have you measured to see which
channels provide the best exposure the
best stickiness for your users as they
engage with that which medium also
provides you the ability to control your
brand and your brand message and be
effective and getting that message to
your audience and then also can you
reach at scale meaning can you reach as
many people as you want to reach can you
do it organically do you have to pay do
you know how many do you know your reach
based on a paid promotion based on the
sum total of followers or people you're
trying to reach how are you measuring
and does it align to your big picture of
what you're trying to do let's get into
the pros and cons here that's why you're
here the number one Pro con and this is
probably the con
the costs are low but they are
increasing fast so what I will say is
those that have already started paying
for social placement have probably
already paid the lowest prices they will
ever pay if you're just getting into it
now it will be somewhat lower but it is
going to constantly increase that's
because the market is growing people are
finding out that this can be effective
and so everyone is jumping on board and
so be prepared that the costs will just
continue to climb now number two reason
for doing this is you get better
exposure you see if you're just doing an
organic post it's going to reach a small
percentage of your followers maybe it
will go outside of that but really
that's all you're doing in order to get
more of your followers you got to pay
and depending upon how many you want to
reach or even beyond followers maybe
you're trying to get more followers
you've got to be willing to spend for
that promotion I have here from 500 to
5,000 it could be double or triple that
depending upon what you're trying to do
gain followers engage with your own
audience or even more one thing that is
making it easier is a lot of the social
platforms are adding functions that will
enable ways for you to engage with ads
without actually leaving that platform
Facebook canvas Twitter cards Instagram
is now allowing some built in calls to
action so that people don't have to
leave that social platform in order to
engage with your ad or engage with the
brand and so there are more and more
functions coming online that will enable
that and you're going to get some good
metrics off of it as well remember that
they are their metrics it's the social
platforms metrics because it's their
platform
now one of the cons to all of this is as
you develop campaigns for each one of
these sites you've got to deliver
creatives in different ad formats in
different size formats depending upon
what you are attempting to do as you can
see here the display ads on YouTube are
different sizes than Instagram they're
different than Facebook different than
LinkedIn so your creatives got to be
pretty much locked in and flexible in
order to go across channels and utilize
them because they all even though there
are you know the standard ad formats it
seems like they're all doing their own
thing and we'll find some consistency
but not always across the board and so
for your ad campaigns you need to be
aware that there's going to be different
sizes available and have your creative
ready to go and make sure that you can
test that in those formats now here's
why I love social placement it's
targeting it's all about data you can
start to develop campaigns based on
specific data points that match the type
of people you want to reach you can do
it with demographics socio graphics even
firma graphics firmer graphics are the
business to business side of
demographics so if you want to reach a
business with a certain amount of people
a certain amount of revenue in a certain
industry that's perma graphics Soccio
graphics are more along the lines of if
you're looking for people that you know
may be retired or just married or just
with a baby a new baby that would be
more so Co graphics and targeting based
on social type of groupings you can also
go for a local or regional targeting you
can go based on interests which Facebook
provides now from a programmatic
standpoint which is where I'm doing
automated advice I can do retargeting
again that's targeting ads based on
people who has
visited my site or maybe they responded
to another campaign visited a landing
page but didn't take action and so I can
retarget them through a programmatic buy
through social channels and again based
on their behavior I may have a high
budget because they showed a high
affinity towards my brand or towards the
offer that was there you see I kind of
look at the organic reach as test
messaging and I'm going to give you a
little bit of a history lesson that back
in the day Direct Mail was the number
one way of reaching an audience and if I
had an audience of 50,000 or you know
even a million people instead of coming
up with a creative and then sending it
to all of my list of a million people
I would only send to about 2% and I
would see what the response rate was
based on that 2% similarly when you do
an email campaign a best practice is to
send a test to about 2% of your list
measure the response adjust anything
that maybe you've done an a/b test where
you sent one message to 2% and another
message to another 2% measure the
response off that and then send the
winner to your larger list this is how
we can view organic posting that ideally
when you do an organic post it might hit
about 5 percent of your audience it's
not going to go far but you can look at
the performance of that organic post and
if it does well especially compared to
other organic posts and there is a good
response rate then I look at that as a
key to hit that promote button and start
building more momentum with that message
now one of the things that a lot of
people have a problem with is
measurement measurement of my campaign
so what I'm showing you here is a
Facebook ad and usually when people are
looking and putting things on Facebook
and advertising they're looking for
engagement the thing is when we start
looking at engagement there are a lot of
ways to engage with this ad and so I
want to highlight just a few here
because there are a couple ways you can
engage with it you can engage by
clicking on the sponsor ad you can
engage with the thumbs up you can engage
by actually um we see here where my tool
go you can engage by doing a like
comment share or you can actually click
on the creative of the ad so there's a
lot of ways you can engage but the thing
is that not all of these engagements are
worth the same amount you see if I get a
comment or a share that means that that
is something that is going to go into
the network feed of anyone who comments
or shares they're going to share it with
their network and so in that way I'm
getting earned media views because
they're sharing it with their network
alike is alike and I really have a hard
time comparing likes with you know the
same degree as comments or shares and
alike is certainly not as good as
getting someone to actually click on the
creative to do what I want them to do so
I'm going to measure that a little
differently and I'm you know I could
lump everything under this cost per
engagement that I spent five thousand
dollars and I got this many clicks and
those clicks could be anything and
that's a cost per engagement it's a
pretty nebulous measurement I'm sure you
can see here so let's go to the next
slide here and we'll take a deeper look
and let me see if I can okay I have to
figure out a way to get rid of all this
there we go good okay now what's the
goal of my campaign the goal of my
campaign is to get people to click the
creative to learn more and beast on that
click now I have my cost of campaign and
if my cost to the campaign was $5,000
then I count the amounts of conversions
the amount of people that clicked the ad
and now I have my cost per click
all right now those people that click
the ad then went to my landing page and
filled out a lead form they converted on
the lead form now I can trace my
facebook ad and I got to get my marker
here because I'm loving this everyone
who clicked on that ad and then everyone
who went to a landing page and my
landing page then converted them
I had my nice little button here that
you know and that all of their
information they filled it out and when
they filled it out they became a lead so
now I can take how much I spent on the
campaign here twenty five hundred
dollars on the campaign I got two
hundred new leads and now I can measure
this campaign to $12.50 cost per lead
and so that's an initial way if I'm
driving people to a destination that I
can measure that's one of mine then I
can start attaching a value to what the
campaign generated okay let me clean all
this up before I go to the next slide
all right
now the next pro and con and this kind
of falls under social placement but it
is advertising placement that tends to
show up on social sites and this is
called paid editorials native
advertising or content syndication
there's a lot of different names fidus
native advertising mamie for the reason
that the ad looks like the content of
the site that you are on and so we see
this if it's advertorials it's companies
that BuzzFeed is a great example of this
where a brand will put content on
BuzzFeed under the brand's name but the
content looks like everything else on
BuzzFeed advertorials
companies that will pay and we see this
also if you've ever seen related
articles that is paid placement of
articles that are basically ads and so
one of the things a reasonable consumer
has to be able to do is distinguish
between what's paid advertising and what
is published editorial content
unfortunately that line is getting
harder and harder to distinguish
everyday main reason is because of
something like this this was a great
example of an infographic that went into
Wired magazine and it looks like any
other type of article in Wired but
there's something I want you to see here
that most people did not see when they
were on this site and right here it says
and I just scribbled over advertisement
in a very small hard-to-see text and so
that is the only thing that tells you
that this is paid placement and so the
upside is you can get a lot of eyeballs
onto something that looks like an
article on a trusted publishers website
the downside is when people finally see
that it's an ad or understand that it's
a pay
placement the credibility might take a
hit so be very careful with that and
make sure it is clearly marked because
this is something that the government
regardless of where you are most
governments are looking very closely at
the type of advertising that looks like
publisher material but it's actually an
ad disclosure is becoming a bigger and
bigger issue in these areas now I let to
start talking about influencers working
with bloggers video personalities
Instagram personalities now one of the
things and this might be pretty obvious
if it's a macro influencer that means
they have a lot of people following them
if they're a micro influencer and this
is something that's arisen over the past
I don't know probably a year or so and
that is instead of paying a lot of money
to one person who has a large audience
what if we look for micro influencers
that have a stronger relationship a
stronger let's say a more isolated type
of message or personality
for example a micro influencer they tend
to have a blog or an Instagram feed
where they focus specifically on fashion
photography Travel food decor they focus
on a specific subject area and so by
finding micro influencers with smaller
audiences but with a more specific focus
that's where a lot of brands have
started to look here or doing a
combination of both now the upside of
all this is that working with a macro
influencer can increase your reach so on
the left side here during the last Super
Bowl class in February
uh-oh D and snapchat we're working
together here and so ality was doing a
great campaign basically uh you know who
cares about the game and it was it was a
pretty good campaign now in doing this
they received fifty five hundred new
snapchat followers
on the day of the Super Bowl more than a
hundred thousand views now they got 2400
campaign mentions and that totaled about
37 thousand impressions 2500 new Twitter
followers 9 thousand new Facebook fans
um so depending upon what kind of budget
those numbers may impress you they may
not another example here is Logan Paul
who is a macro influencer sour patch
kids did a video campaign it generated
120,000 new snapchat followers for Sour
Patch uh you know 6.8 thousand
impressions are million impressions
generated five hundred thousand of those
one of the first day of the campaign 26
thousand screenshots and 1,900 Twitter
mentions now that campaign with Logan
Paul and the sour patch kids cost over
$100,000 so depending upon who you are
you might be looking at the return on
investment what does $100,000 get you
working with a macro influencer to some
brands this is good this is acceptable
this moves the needle and that's what
they want to others they may say no
thank you I'm going to spend my money
elsewhere and that's okay it depends on
who you are your brand and what you're
attempting to do another example of this
this is Megan ranks she has 2.3 million
subscribers she works with Old Navy
Old Navy works with both macro micro
influencers now her campaign reached
over 1 million of her 2.3 million
followers basically she just created a
number of videos with Old Navy products
clothing things like that see the
downside of working with these macro
influencers and maybe some micro
influencers is the price like I said the
Logan Paul sour patch campaign was a
hundred thousand dollars if you're
working with a macro influencer that's
the kind of money you should expect to
pay one quote that I found is
the average price of a hundred thousand
for an influencer with over five million
followers and that is the cost to create
one video post for each of the three
major platforms Facebook Instagram
snapchat now you may you may get away
single tweets can cost anywhere between
50 and $100 a high-visibility blogger
with a larger audience it may cost about
a hundred thousand for an article a
single review from a blogger could cost
as much as ten thousand dollars and
Honda working with one influencer paid
$10,000 for a two-minute video so this
is where working with influencers is a
you know depending upon who you're
working with the prices are going up
however you also need to be careful
because this is where things get a
little dicey you see right now there's
no standard there is no uh you know
there's some going rates and a lot of
the micro influencers want macro
influencer prices a lot of the macro
influencers no other macro influencers
are making and so they're going to
demand as much if not more and so their
price points are everywhere now it
starts at the bottom if you want to pay
for social placement the cheapest and
you know where you can start it's just
sponsoring a tweet or sponsoring a post
you just start there see what the
results are and move from there
then purchase some social ads that is
advertising on social sites for a
specific demographic Geographic you can
add more data points in order to have
them focused on your audience then you
can move into some integrated or program
mattifies again you're using data data
points to reach a specific audience
video advertising is highly effective
that requires a lot of resources for
many companies and so to develop the
video to write the video to edit it to
you know in a lot of times people will
say it doesn't have to be high quality
I always kind of raised my eyebrow at
that comment because I don't really see
where low quality is is doing great
people like high quality stuff and and
and maybe I should say people like high
quality that sometimes looks low quality
but it's high quality it's been it's
been produced and it's been written well
and it has a specific point and that's
what it's for
now that next to the paid advertising
that's going to cost you some uh and I
that's one where I always put a caution
on that that yes it works but when
people find out it's paid ads who the
credibility hit off of that is a little
bit but like I said for some it works an
influencer marketing it's at the very
top of the paid social pyramid so this
is sort of the hierarchy of what you're
looking at when you're budgeting now
influencer marketing is brand new now
granted this couple years in here but it
is those shiniest thing right now when
it comes to social media and you've got
to watch out because sometimes some
brands have realized that they're
throwing you know tens of thousands of
dollars at a twenty year old who has
generated a million followers in that
twenty year old is not the most business
savvy all of a sudden they're having all
this money thrown at them but they don't
work like a brand works they don't run
on the same schedule nor do they have
the same goals and so you're working
with people that they're outside of the
typical corporate arena and they like
that
they are independent they've built this
on their own and they don't want anyone
to tell them how to do what they do so
because this is so new there is a lot of
unknown going on about it a lot of times
in speaking with other brands that have
done a lot of influencer marketing one
of the most frustrating points is the
unfamiliarity with contracts and in
dealing with some of these influencers
that really don't understand business
they want the money but they don't
understand
two contracts schedules and things like
that also if you're doing this you can't
forget to track and measure one example
here is the director of marketing from
Orchid Island juice company is saying
especially on snapchat you have no way
of knowing what kind of impact it's
making for your brand
there's just no measurement that they
are able to put in there to know the
return now one study says that
businesses are getting six dollars and
fifty cents in revenue for each dollar
spent on influencer marketing another
study says that 65 percent of marketers
can't find a return on investment so
which is it be very careful where you're
getting your information from and who
funds the study that's going to be my
first bit of information but also if you
can if you're doing any amount of
influence or marketing some of the
things that you can do offer discount
codes specifically for that campaign
that bloggers that personality that they
can give to their audience create an
individual landing page for that
campaign make sure you tag things
properly or even create an individual
URL that they can share that way it will
give you an ideal what's going on but
banking and a point A to point B
measurement is very difficult and that's
the number one frustration for marketers
in the social space now one of the
downsides a lot of brands have expressed
frustration in that when you work
especially with a macro influencer they
want to do things the way they do them
they don't want to always be told what
to do for a brand and so as a brand if
you are paying an influencer you have to
give up some level of brand control
because you're allowing this influencer
to recast your brand in a way that their
audience will accept it just can't come
across as a blatant advertisement unless
that's their policy and that's how
everything's going to
oh no they want to do it their way and
especially if you're asking an
influencer to create a video or create
something specifically for you you're
going to have to give up some level of
control and remember a lot of these
people are Mavericks and that's the way
that they have built their audience and
so they're going to want to do it their
way
now this can come back and bite you
Disney has felt this in the relationship
with the blogger PewDiePie or the
YouTube personality PewDiePie one of the
top video bloggers around the world with
the largest audience and he started
getting in trouble and saying things
that were not good and Disney had to
separate themselves from him and no
longer with the contract there he lost
money Disney was associated with some of
the things he was doing so be very
careful about what you're giving up as
well as make sure you've done your
research on this influencer that they
are going to reflect well on your brand
so again you're dealing with
personalities and you're dealing with
personalities who are outside of the
corporate structure they have built
their audience on their own and so they
don't like to be told what to do at one
agency quote here from an unnamed source
is that working with influencers is a
headache and they said they're not aware
of things that are just very obvious
like sticking to a schedule that they
don't post because they don't feel like
it but to the agency that's the
nightmare because we have a schedule we
you know you're part of a larger picture
and just because you don't feel like it
you know you we can't do that and so
you're working with a lot of young
influencers who may not understand the
critical nature of a schedule and they
may not be mature enough to handle
everything that the demands of this
contract of working now also some of the
things you have to deal with is
skepticism
from the followers of the influencer an
example here is a very strong influencer
who's talks about that they always
carried a carton of their favorite juice
and the top comment was the that they
were the biggest sellout ever uh and so
the rear audience or how their followers
respond is not always predictable and if
it doesn't fit their voice if it doesn't
fit their personality and if it comes
off as a brayton blatant brand placement
boy you're going to be in for trouble
because people don't always trust ads
and they don't always trust the
influencer and so there may be backlash
based on how it was done or even just a
natural skepticism but be prepared that
it may not always go the way you want it
to go
I know I'm presenting a lot of downsides
here but this is what you need to know
in order to do this correctly next thing
is be aware many influencers they may
have gained a certain amount of
influence but followers like anything
else are commodity here's an example of
a company where you can buy followers I
can buy $2,500 $2,500 for $29 I can buy
10,000 likes for less than $70 and this
is all for Instagram they that you can
do this for any social media you can go
out and buy followers there are click
farms there are all kinds of things and
I'm sure you've seen these in the news
of these just racks of phones computers
that are there per sole purpose is
creating false followers and false likes
and that's any anyone can go out and buy
that for their own personal brand now
there are some companies that will audit
an influencer before you pay with error
or approach them but again remember that
this is kind of an arms race the
companies that do the audits of the
influencers they're trying to keep ahead
of these companies that are trying to
make money and there is a market of
bloggers video bloggers Instagram
personalities that are always trying to
inflate their numbers because the larger
their numbers the more they can demand
from a contract and if you've done any
amount of research into influencer
marking one of the things that blew me
away is as I was looking and doing some
more research on this when I was looking
for articles about influencer marketing
I found three different types of
articles there were articles from
influencers talking about how effective
influencer marketing was there were
articles from the media talking about
how awesome it worked
with influencers are and then also from
providers writing articles about how
awesome working with influencers are and
here's an example from an article that
ranked in the top 10 for influencer
marketing at the bottom of the article
if you have any questions if you want
professional guidance launching your
very own of course hyperlinked
influencer marketing campaign get in
touch with me there is a lot of media
hype about influencer marketing and most
of what you will find in the search
results are a result of influencers
writing articles about working with
influencers providers service providers
writing about it and the media who's
absolutely in love with it because it
kind of fits with them as well be
prepared for what you will see and this
goes along with every new shiny thing
when it comes to internet marketing
you're going to have those who
immediately benefit from it writing
articles about it you're going to have
those who sell the services writing
articles about it and they know how to
get those articles in the top results so
be sure what you read learn from it but
also deal with it with a healthy amount
of skepticism here's the bottom line
and I'm going to give it to you from all
the research that I've done and also
from campaigns that I've worked on if
you're going to use an influencer number
one it doesn't matter whether it's a
micro or macro influencer you find the
one that works best with you typically
it's an influencer who already likes
your brand who already does something
that's related to your brand and if they
have an affinity for your brand they're
going to care about how its presented
and they're going to be much more
personally invested and back if you work
with an influencer who already has an
affinity to your brand they may lower
their price just to work with you that's
what a lot of some of the experience
that I've seen and then also those that
have worked with influencers is finding
those that you know what they fit
perfectly and there's a great
relationship they want to see the brand
succeed you want to see it and so it
matches
because of that they have the right
audience they have the audience it's
going to be receptive to their paid
sponsorship or paid ad because that
legally has to be disclosed you want to
make sure that audience is right in line
knowing that as its disclosed that this
is a paid advertisement and that they
are getting paid in order to talk about
this you want to make sure you've got an
audience that's going to listen and not
revolt and that they will accept that
message and finally it's a perfect mix
when you've got the right personality
the right audience that we then have a
partnership on keeping the brand but
also allowing a certain amount of
creative flexibility for that influence
or personality to tell their own story
that's what the bottom line and hey
right now we've got time for questions
so I look forward to hearing your
questions about a lot of information
here great that's wonderful Matt that
was an amazing wrap-up on the on a
really a new topic for a lot of people I
know that social selling is a is a big
issue that is or a big topic that is is
really important for marketers and sales
people alike and so we get a lot of
questions about that we we actually have
a quite a few questions bubbling up and
on that topic of social selling Karl
asked that if you're having difficulty
now social selling is a new sales
technique where you basically as a sales
person or as a marketer you don't you
don't use emails or phone calls that
sort of thing you try to Chum up through
influencers or even prospects via social
media in a very soft no soft sell long
term relationship building process and
that goes a long way to building
relationships with influencers but Karl
asks if you're having difficulty with
your charming your charming skills at
social selling with an influencer how
can you approach an influencer who may
not already be advertises as a paid or
accepting funds type of influencer how
can you approach a trusted influences
say hey you know what we have some we
have some marketing dollars I was
wondering if there's anything you could
you'd be willing to do for us what's a
good way to approach a reluctant or a
new influencer who doesn't actually have
a a paid presence already boy that
that's its own webinar right there uh
just on the approach uh itself is so
critical because there's a lot of ways
to screw it up um you know and and you
know it so I'll tell you you know I I
get pitches and what amazes me about the
pitch is when in the pitch that they
make to me it's more about them and what
they want and their offer rather than
how it benefits me and my audience any
influencer blogger uh they got where
they are because of their audience and
giving information that their audience
wants if you approach them and saying
hey we want you to do this because we're
this or we're you know you've lost them
so the first thing that's vitally
important in making that pitch is
finding out okay do we have a compatible
product that will fit their message do
we have a compatible business that will
fit their message and how will they
benefit not just financially but how
will they benefit out of their audience
benefit from us advertising in some way
how does it help this influencer build
value or build more trust or or build
more relationship with their audience
because that's ultimately what they want
it's their audience that's got them
where they are yeah that's great that's
excellent advice so Lorraine has a
question do you have any advice on how
to go about insuring the influencer is
doing their part for example if they're
supposed to be promoting on their own
networks how can you be sure that there
pulling up their end of the bargain
well short of just having someone keep
an eye on it um you know there are some
third-party services uh you know but
that's one of those things that you know
you've got to have trust in the
relationship the number one thing I
would do is just you know have them kind
of report to me that okay when you've
done these things let us know chances
are uh you know depending upon what
you're doing you are checking and
reviewing what they do before they post
it especially if it's a video or an ad
or a post um you know if it's not
written into your contract to review all
communications before they go out to be
sure if it's the brand message to be for
sure it fits your personality as well as
their personality so in that way you'll
know what's going out who approved it
you know there there is a schedule that
that and obviously when they do it you
should be able to see it and know that
it was completed a lot of this has
worked out in the contract and agreement
wonderful great now now here's a
question from Armando is like is there
ever a scenario where an ongoing paid
campaign is warranted for example social
media campaigns tend to be only days or
weeks long is there an exception to that
rule um some are yeah I'm trying to
think here what
really when I when I get into more of
the long term type social campaigns then
it's mainly what I'm looking at is from
a mainly programmatic standpoint where
I'm using it in conjunction with okay so
let's say I did a paid search campaign
and people went to my landing page and
it clicked on a few things
they will then drop into my programmatic
campaign which will target them on
social networks and only people that
have seen that landing page and have not
yet
converted or become a lead they will be
the only ones that see that ad those
types of campaigns I run for a longer
period of time because they are lead
capture campaigns or lead recapture you
know kind of like a retargeting campaign
to get those people back in that's the
only type of thing that I would describe
is more of a long term whereas yes most
of social is a very short term for
example I remember seeing something
about Facebook ads that they are seen
the most amount within like three days a
Facebook ad is typically seen about 50
times uh and so after two days your
message is already old if you're on
Facebook and so the speed at which you
have to keep up with your campaigns
because there's nothing worse than an
old ad that you have seen a hundred
times in a week you're no longer really
paying attention to it other than
there's that ad again yeah that's a
that's a good point effort it said
numerous times that the first question
people ask themselves when they see an
ad is have I seen this before and the
more times you get that it's like a it's
like having it's like having CNN news on
four all day long you keep seeing it
over and over again okay we just have
one last question from Daphne and Daphne
asks what are some you have any more
negotiating tips that you could use with
paid placement when you're talking
publishers for example things such as
bundling
no um yeah I mean you look at all the
ways you know not wait a second is this
from my influence or standpoint this is
no actually this is from what could be
it could be either but this is this is
clearly from an advertiser's style okay
um I mean yeah I would I would be
looking at you know so one of those was
a cost for developing a video for each
of the three major networks so what
they're doing is not just recycling the
same video across three different
platforms they're creating a flat
they're creating a video for each
platform because this gets back to the
media is the message people are going to
watch a facebook video much differently
than people on snapchat with what were
or Instagram would view a video you can
see that in the metrics and so it's got
to be a different format it's got to be
faster it's got to be you know made a
little differently so simply you know
making sure that they are adapting the
message to the medium that they're using
and then also that it's adapted to the
campaign it's a and we are driving
people to a specific you know maybe it's
a shared landing page or something like
that but other than that I would I would
audit every influencer with one of these
they're one of these audit sites for
their followers because it's a lot of
your mid-level and micro influencers
they're they're the ones that tend to
pad their numbers because they want the
big they want the big numbers so they
want the much the macro numbers however
I've seen some macros even paying for
additional likes and followers so always
use one of those audits and kind of get
a sense of the percentage of bots that
are following them um you know they may
know about it they may be paying for it
you never know but then also you know
what's the schedule how many posts what
are they going to do how are they going
to react if their audience doesn't like
it it's it's really kind of angling to
answer as many questions as you can
before you have that agreement yeah
that's a good that's a good point
especially
even writing in the contract thing about
what happens if the if they get some
backlash what are they going to do so
that's really interesting well great
thank you very much Matt this was an
amazing webinar and we're getting a lot
of great feedback already thank you Dan
got a lot of good stuff out of it so
everyone who's listening you will also
be getting a recording of this webinar
so you can review it at a future date
thanks again for joining us and join us
again next Thursday actually next
Wednesday where we're going to be doing
another direct marketing and digital
marketing webinar and on some secrets
about pay-per-click advertising so if
there's anything else you like to say
feel free to email us and contact us at
the at the at the webinar invite address
and I have been very happy to host you
I'm Dan beaver and I just want to say
one more thanks to Matt Bailey thank you
Dan thanks everyone have a great rest of
your afternoon evening or morning bye
bye
[Music]